[MUSIC]
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So hello once again.
Welcome to Android
Design in Action.
For those of you who aren't
watching live and who were
watching the YouTube
pre-roll--
or YouTube recording, we had
some interesting technical
difficulties.
So we're just going
to start over.
And this will, hopefully,
be the better
version of the show episode.
My name is Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: Hey guys.
My name is Adam Koch.
ROMAN NURIK: And today we're
going to actually show a demo
of the I/O app.
We'll talk a little bit about
what that is in a second.
We'll also do a deep dive-- a
narrow dive, as you pointed
out before--
into sharing, as well
as fullscreen UIs.
So we have a lot of
content to cover.
This may run the longer
than 30 minutes.
If it does, then really
sorry about that.
But too bad.
So let's jump into the
I/O app real quick.
So the I/O app is an app that
our team developed that helped
Google I/O 2013 attendees find
their way around the
conference, take a look at what
interesting sessions were
playing, as well as
interact with
folks socially on Google+.
Obviously, this is a
responsively-designed app.
There's a phone and
tablet version.
It supports 7-inch, 10-inch.
Things scale up progressively.
So it's an overall
a quite nice app.
And we're to do a deep dive
on some of the details.
Anything you want to add
before we jump in?
ADAM KOCH: I think we mentioned
on the previous run
that it's an open-source app.
So right now, the source
code that's out
there is the 2012 version.
So, last year's version.
But later this year, or
hopefully in the coming
months, we will be
open-sourcing the
2013 version as well.
ROMAN NURIK: Yes.
OK.
So let's jump into the demo.
And let's hope it
works this time.
So here's the app running on
10-inch and 7-inch devices.
ADAM KOCH: 4-inch.
ROMAN NURIK: I said that wrong
the first time, too.
So 4-inch and 10-inch devices.
And you'll notice that there are
a lot of similarities in
the visual language.
And we'll talk about
that in a second.
But also, just in terms of
navigation, on the phone you
have tabs representing your
three top-level sections.
You have your schedule,
which is personalized.
Your Explore as well
as your stream.
Explore contains things like
map, and list of tracks, and
things like that.
And then on a tablet, we blow
it up into a dashboard UI.
Not actually the dashboard
pattern, with the four
six-pack of icons, but it's
really kind of like a what
happening now type of screen,
where you see your current
schedule, upcoming sessions, as
well as the stream of, what
are people buzzing about?
What are people talking about
on Google+ about the
conference?
So it's kind of interesting.
There are a lot of touches that
we added to this app over
previous years.
And we'll do a deep
dive on that now.
So the first thin I wanted to
call out was just the diagonal
patterns that we
use throughout.
And this is something that
has been around in
Android for a while.
More recently with the Google
Play Store, as well as Google
Play apps redesigns, we've kind
of moved away from that.
But we held on to this
pattern in our app.
So what I'm really talking about
here is this kind of
diagonal-line pattern that you
can see here in the tabs--
it may not come out well
in the video feed--
as well as over here in the
Schedule Time heading.
And the same goes
for the tablet.
The background, actually, of
this area is that diagonal
line pattern.
So it's just part of the visual
language of the app.
And we use it throughout as a
way to partly communicate, or
partly introduce contrast rather
than using different
colors, but also just as a
visual stylistic choice.
So the next thing I wanted
to talk about was, in the
schedule, we actually have
these borderless buttons,
these secondary touch targets.
And this is something that is
kind of cool if you have a
common other action
for a line item.
So here, rather than just
choosing this session that's
in my schedule, I can just
choose to see all items that
are in my schedule
for that time.
Or all available sessions
in that time.
Another one of my favorites is
the Contextual Action bar.
So let's say you wanted to share
something immediately,
rather than jumping
into the session.
You could long press.
And you actually get the
contextual actions that you
can take on there.
You can also switch
to other sessions.
And you can't actually select
anything else, since you can't
really do actions on them.
Let's see.
So moving on to the
Explore tab.
This is actually something
that's fairly subtle, and a
lot of you that have used this
app may not have noticed this.
So we have this map
area at the top.
And something that we do is,
on press, we actually
desaturate the background.
So you can see that the yellow
these yellow road lines, they
actually become gray.
Another app that does this, I
believe, is Google Currents.
One of the reasons we decided to
do it-- and this is just a
neat trick.
It doesn't really add
too much here.
But it's something that helps
prevent color collisions
between your touch highlight,
your semi-transparent blue
touch highlight, and the
background content.
We also do this in other areas,
I think, for Avatar
icons, which we can
show later.
And then, obviously,
we're using
different weights of Roboto.
Here in the tracks list
we use Roboto Light.
And actually, for sessions that
have passed-- you can't
really see this here, because
it's after the conference.
But during the conference, past
sessions were actually
typeset in Roboto Light to give
them a little less visual
weight, so that your eye can
naturally focus on things that
are yet to come.
Another item in the visual
language is, we use these
circle masks.
And we do this throughout.
We use these in the
stream here.
So you'll notice that here in
the stream, each poster, each
Google+ person that's posted
something, is in a circle.
And this actually is shown as
well on a phone if you jump
into, say the Track Details.
So you'll see that at the top
left, we use this track icon
that's inside of a circle.
And the reason for using
circles, just as a general
stylistic choice, is it's
a cleaner visual.
It's a little more light.
Having a lot of boxes and
squares can instantly make
something feel a little rigid,
make your app feel
a little too rigid.
So just introducing circles
where appropriate--
it's not a universal thing, just
throw circles at stuff
and see what happens--
It may help introduce a little
bit of softness or warmth.
ADAM KOCH: Kind of makes sense
for the Google+ stream as
well, because the Google+
app also uses the
circles for the avatars.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
Another one of my favorites is
some tweaks we did to Search.
So if we press the Search button
here, you'll notice
that you have common keywords.
And this is something that, in
the future, we may want to
tweak to Recent Searches.
But here are common keywords
that you can search across the
session corpus on.
And we added this Query
Refinement, which is actually
really easy for developers.
You simply add a single flag,
and pressing this button
basically populates the search
field with that.
So you can start with that
Search and then edit
it as you see fit.
And then the last thing I wanted
to mention on the home
screen personally was the
View Pager margins.
So as we switch between
different tabs, you'll notice
that the margins, there's about
a 16-dip margin there.
And they actually use a somewhat
beveling effect.
Very, very subtle.
It's not a very heavy
drop shadow.
But this beveling effect, first
of all, it introduces
more consistency when you
look at the tablet app.
Each of these, I don't want to
call them cards, but each of
these panes of content
is actually slightly
raised on it bevel.
It helps communicate that these
are the same thing if
you have a phone and a tablet.
Just on a phone, it's helping to
further add a little bit of
dimensionality without going too
deep into [INAUDIBLE], or
anything like that.
ADAM KOCH: I think by
default, there's no
margin between them.
So adding something there
is something we
should think about.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So, and actually, on a tablet--
we talked about that.
Yeah.
I think that was all that I
wanted to mention about the
Home screen.
Anything else you wanted
to mention, Adam,
before we move on?
ADAM KOCH: Are we covering
this stream later?
ROMAN NURIK: No.
Feel free to talk about
it if you want.
ADAM KOCH: I mean, compared to
the 2012 app, Roman actually
re-designed the way that
the stream looks here.
And so, avatars around, and
then there's this area for
content, if there's images
available for those posts or
repost, reshare.
There this transparent overlay
that shows for certain types
of post content.
So you can see here, there's
this little overlay image to
indicate that there's an image
being shared here.
In this case, it's a
video, so there's a
little video overlay.
ROMAN NURIK: And we actually
used a center
crop technique there.
So whatever size, whatever
width the stream is--
I think we fixed the height.
And generally, this is not
something you want to do on
tablets if you have really
wide stream items.
But using the same sorts of
crop techniques makes sure
that each of these photos or
media items, media overlays,
are a fixed size.
But the content, which can be
in various aspect ratios,
stays within that.
And I think we talked about
that last time.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
And then two other
minor points.
One, as the images load,
there's a very subtle
animation as they snap in.
And the other thing I wanted to
mention is, this fragment
is very responsive.
You'll see it used in many
locations in the app.
And so in this case, it's
approximately the same width
on both tablet and phone.
In other cases, it may
take up a bigger
portion of the screen.
But it scales nicely depending
on the amount of width that's
available to it.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
Let's jump into a
track detail.
So let's jump into the Android
track here on both screens.
I really like this demo setup.
ADAM KOCH: Once it's
finally working.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
Hopefully next time, it'll be
less quirky in the beginning.
OK.
So a couple things for the
session, or tracking detail,
as we call this.
So the first is, you'll notice
that there are very similar
navigational elements.
First, on a tablet, we do
have a two-pane UI.
On a phone we have
a single-pane UI.
On a phone, you actually have
tabs to let you switch between
the different parts,
or different
items within a track.
On a phone you have that.
On a tablet, you have a spinner
at the top that lets
you switch between those.
So if I go from Sessions to
Office Hours, it will just
switch between that and
Sandbox, for example.
One of the nice things that we
wanted to mention is that you
do have contextual action
bar support here.
So you can even select one item,
so view one session, and
then long press to select other
items, and then take
action on those.
Actually, in this case, there's
no actions I could
take, because this one
is in my schedule.
But if I only select things that
are not in my schedule, I
can instantly add those all to
my schedule all at once.
So we also wanted to mention
that the track icons-- again,
track icons is one of the things
we added this year.
We made sure that every track
had some sort of visual
identifier to help
differentiate
it from other tracks.
So we use those track icons
in a lot of places.
On a tablet, we use them
in the header here.
So if I switch to, say, the
Google+ track, you notice that
the header actually changes
the icon to Google+.
Let's see what else we have.
So, another minor point is,
every UI element that is
interactive has touch
feedback.
So if I put my finger on here,
I just press down on here,
you'll notice that there's that
blue overlay that covers
it that indicates that something
is happening.
Also, the same would work if
you used the keyboard or
something to focus that area.
Another minor point is that on
a tablet, the track spinner,
as well as the session
detail heading, they
have the same height.
And there's no interactional
reason for it.
It's just a visual way
to align things.
I don't want to talk about
which principle that is,
because I probably don't know.
But definitely, it's one way to
ensure that there's visual
balance across your UI.
It's to align things
where possible.
If there's no natural point of
alignment, it doesn't make
sense to do that.
But in this case we thought that
it would make sense to
align them.
Let's see.
So one thing we can't demo here
is the Portrait Mode.
And we talked about this
very briefly last week.
But in Portrait Mode, if you
were to hold this tablet in
portrait, you would actually
have a sliding pane layout.
So this left pane would
initially be invisible.
But if you were to slide the
Details section over to the
right, you would slide
out that left pane.
And this is one way to reconcile
having the smaller
amount of width available
on a 10-inch or
7-inch device in portrait.
But making sure that you still
have access to the same
content to maintain the
functional parity across
portrait and landscape.
So again, a minor point.
Not something we can
demo right now.
And we already talked about
the track icons
in the action bar.
So anything else we should
cover for just
this section here?
ADAM KOCH: Um.
ROMAN NURIK: Those are
some of my favorites.
Oh.
Actually, we'll cover
that in a bit.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
We can jump into
session detail.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So for the session details,
this is one
of my favorite parts.
So one of the things we did
was, we moved the Add To
Schedule button from
the Action Bar.
So it used to be this button
over here that would add
whatever you're currently
looking at to the Action Bar.
Rachel Garb from the Android
User Experience Team actually
said, it's not really a good
place for a key fundamental
action like that, something
that should really be
immediately visible
and immediately
gain the user's attention.
Because most of the time they're
going to be looking at
sessions, and they're going to
be wanting to add them to
their schedule.
Another thing is that, we
actually had a Help overlay.
We had a dialogue pop-up that
said, hey, press this plus
button to add the session
to your schedule.
And that was just
too indirect.
So we wanted to make it
a little more direct.
And we basically moved that item
from the Action Bar to an
inline button here, this
In Schedule button.
So one cool thing about this
it sticks to the top.
So while you're viewing session
details, you at any
point may want to actually
decide, hey, this is
interesting enough.
I want to add this
to my schedule.
So we decided to make it stick
to the top so that, as you
make the decision, it's
always there.
And the same goes for
tablet, actually.
It's a little less noticeable
for tablet.
But it's the same behavior.
Another thing is that there's
this subtle animation.
And this is actually only for
Android 4.0 and higher.
As soon as you add something
to your schedule, there's a
very subtle animation.
The plus becomes a check
box, or a check mark.
And it animates then to say,
hey, it has now been added.
It's almost a subtle
reinforcement that the action
has really taken place,
and it's now
really in your schedule.
Very, very subtle.
On earlier versions of the
platform, we simply
just show and hide.
There's some very basic
switching logic to do that.
Let's see.
So another thing was just
reinforcing that visual
language of using circles
throughout.
Each of the avatars here, each
of the speakers, are circles.
And if you notice, when you
press on them, they
desaturate.
Again very, very subtle touch.
If you generally have fairly
simple content, you don't
really need it.
In this case, for avatars,
it's probably not really
adding that much.
But if you have large photos
that may potentially clash
with the overlay, you
may want to do that.
Let's see.
What else?
ADAM KOCH: I guess you'll see
the diagonal lines here in the
header again.
And also, the section
headers are a
recommended pattern here.
You've got the all caps
and the small
font with the underline.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
We could have used tabs.
We could definitely
have used tabs.
And I think, in previous
versions of the
app, we did use tabs.
But we've switched more to a
single scrolling experience.
Where basically, rather than
doing a lot of navigation back
and forth between content, you
can slowly scroll down and
really peruse what's
available.
So you go from Session Details
to Speakers, and then to more
stuff, like Submit Feedback.
ADAM KOCH: And of course, each
of these sections is a dynamic
in its height.
The description could vary.
The number of speakers
could vary.
And these more links at the
bottom also are dynamic.
There could be many of them or
fewer, depending on what sort
of session it is.
ROMAN NURIK: So one thing I
wanted to mention on a tablet,
I guess, is the consistent
iconography.
And this is, again, introducing
some consistency
in the visuals that you use in
your app is just as important
as following the visual design
guidelines on Android, right?
So you want to make sure that
your app is internally
consistent.
One of the other ways in which
we do that, outside of using
the diagonal line visual element
and the circles, is
this unification of presentation
of sessions that
are in your schedule.
So first, you'll notice that
there are these little
ribbons, or bookmarks,
that have a little
check mark in them.
And these are sessions that
are in my schedule.
And the same is mirrored here,
on the right, in that Add to
Schedule button.
If I look at a session that's
not added, you'll see the
inverse state of that.
And pressing that immediately
shows the
little check mark there.
So these subtle things help
create a unified visual
language across your app.
So let's see.
We talked about that.
Oh.
One other thing was, on Session
Details, you'll notice
that on tablets we use a larger
font, as well as Roboto
Light for the text here.
And that's party because it's
generally a little easier.
First of all, it helps mitigate
long line lengths,
long line-measure disasters.
But in this case, it really
helps make the content feel
more balanced, since there's
a lot of space here.
And if this were any smaller if
this were Roboto regular,
it may feel a little
too dense.
So using that really
helped on tablets.
ADAM KOCH: The line heights
are taller as well, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
The line heights are ever
so slightly taller.
And we use the Resources
Framework
slash Styles for this.
Let's see.
So, let's quickly look at Submit
Feedback on the phone.
So Submit Feedback is, let's
say you've seen a session.
And I can do that in
template as well.
But let's say you've
seen a session.
And now you want to
provide feedback.
So this is actually a custom
control that we wrote.
It's very simple.
It's based on a seek bar.
There are some crazy nine
patches in there.
But it's really just
a fancy seek bar.
The idea is that you
have this slider.
It's a sliding scale
for ratings.
And we use the standard
accent color.
We call it I/O Blue.
We use the standard accent color
rather than Holo Blue,
in this case, because we wanted
to introduce a little
bit more color consistency
throughout.
And then at the bottom, you'll
notice that we actually use
that same blue for the
radio buttons, as
well as the text fields.
So the little underline
in the text field is
also the same color.
And the way we did that is, we
actually used Android Holo
Colors from Jerome Van Der
Linden, I believe.
And Android Holo Colors
basically lets you throw in
your accent color in order to
generate the assets for you so
your designers don't have to
sit and like draw out.
So I think that was it
for session feedback.
Let's jump into the map.
And I think we're at about
20 minutes now.
So we should probably
hurry up.
But let's look at
the map here.
So here's the map.
And it's using the new
Android Maps API v2--
I forgot the name of that.
But it's using the new
Android Maps API.
And you'll notice some of the
interesting things here.
First, each of these map
markers is customized.
So it's using that standard
blue-purple-red gradient
inside there.
Next is, when you open up, let's
say the Sandbox area,
you'll notice that
we use that same
styling for showing icons.
This is the same styling on a
tablet, where you'd see the
title at the top left, some sort
of subtitle below, and
then the icon on
the top right.
And we use, actually, a subtle
gradient as well, to hint that
this is part of the
visual language.
There's no real meaning to it.
Let's see.
What else for this?
Oh.
So we actually used Bold
Condensed here for the text.
So for very long--
that's a really long one.
Yeah.
So developed for good,
for example.
For very long titles, Roboto
Condensed helps compress that
horizontally.
So let's quickly look
at the pop-up.
So let's say I actually
decide to look at
what's in this room.
So if I touch here, on a tablet,
you see a separate
pane pop up.
And it's kind of a
floating pane.
Whereas on a phone,
you actually
get a separate activity.
Now, if on a tablet, I decide
to jump into one of these, I
can touch in, and it will
load it right here.
And again, you see all that
those same consistent buttons,
like the Add to Schedule
Button, and so on.
But you also get this bread
crumb at the top.
So if I really quickly want to
jump back to Room 8, I can
either press back, or I
can just press this.
And then I could obviously
dismiss this as well.
You notice that showing that
pop-up actually automatically
pans the map, so that whatever
was currently in the center
remains at the visible center.
OK.
So I think that was the map.
Is there anything
else we should--
talk about the live stream?
ADAM KOCH: We can very
quickly cover it.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I think we knew this was
going to go long.
So it's fine.
ADAM KOCH: So this is the live
stream activity so you can
watch the sessions
that are being
streamed live on YouTube.
We just plugged in some of
our own values here.
So we've got ADIA inside ADIA.
But we can't actually show
this on the phone.
But on the tablet here, on the
left side, you'll see one pane
broken out.
And on the right side, there's
a split between tabs for the
social stream from Google+,
and then captions.
So some of the live streams
actually had
live captions as well.
On a phone device, it'll just
be collapsed into the three
tabs that fall below
the video.
And then I guess you can go
full screen as well here.
So this is the YouTube
API for Android.
So it sort of comes with all
the standard bells and
whistles that you could expect
from the YouTube player.
And we'll actually cover a
little bit more on the full
screen modes shortly after
this I/O app recap.
That's pretty much it, right?
ROMAN NURIK: Well, we can
show the full screen
really quick, right?
ADAM KOCH: All right.
Let's see if it works.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
That should work.
ADAM KOCH: OK.
ROMAN NURIK: And then you
can toggle the controls.
We'll actually talk about
this in a moment
with toggling controls.
You notice that almost
everything, the status bar,
the navigation bar, and the
action bar, all fade away,
leaving just the content.
And we'll talk about that,
actually, in the deep dive for
full-screen UIs.
All right.
So really quickly, just to
recap, there's a lot of cool
things in this app.
It will be open source
very soon.
Well, hopefully very,
We're just waiting on a couple
things to be sorted out before
we can do that.
And yeah.
It's been a pleasure
working on it.
There's some things that
we probably do
differently, right?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
Actually, at I/O, there was
an app clinic live.
And one of the comments that
Rito gave us is about the
refresh button.
ROMAN NURIK: Right.
So we have this manual Refresh
button at the top.
And when we actually sinking
content will show a spinner
and place but one of the
comments that Ian and Rito
gave us was that, why
do you need Refresh?
This should automatically
sink in the background.
Refresh should not be
a primary action.
It should be secondary if
anything, if at all.
we do actually have Google Cloud
Messaging enabled here.
So we do refresh on push
from the server.
So we could probably very simply
remove the Refresh
button, or move it into
the overflow.
So definitely, especially if
you have a sink adapter, if
you have Google Cloud Messaging
turned on, you don't
necessarily need Refresh.
So we may remove that
for next year.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
I think maybe one other purpose
of the refresh button
was to refresh the
Google+ stream.
So we had some limitations there
in terms of how we would
fetch new content and actually
display in line there.
But hopefully in a future
version, we can get rid of
that Refresh button and
intelligently refresh as needed.
ROMAN NURIK: All right.
So that was a whopping
demo of the I/O app.
We probably have like
three seconds for
the rest our content.
But there's a lot of
good content left.
Let's see.
So let's jump back
into the slides.
There they are.
So that was the I/O app.
Again, if you install it now and
just play around with it,
here's the QR code.
But let's jump into sharing.
ADAM KOCH: All right so go
through this very quickly this
shallow dive and sharing content
so I sort of talk
about a few things.
You're sharing's something
that's very system-wide.
And so I think convention is
very important when it comes
something like sharing.
So hopefully, whenever you to
use a share action, you always
use the native Android
Share icon.
That's actually, surprisingly,
something we see done
incorrectly many times.
So definitely do that.
Also, avoid hard coding to
specific apps or services.
So there may be a specific
use case where it's
useful to do that.
But for the vast majority of
cases, you should really be
calling out to the system share
intent-- which, I'll
show you some examples of
that in just a second--
rather the hard coding to fire
up a specific app or a
specific service that
receives sharing.
I think Android users have just
become really, really
used to being able to use
whichever application or
service they want to use.
And so when they don't
get that, they're
just going to be unhappy.
And that's going to be a
frustrating experience.
ROMAN NURIK: One other thing
I wanted to note is that
sometimes you want to do a
really rich integration with a
certain network, like
Twitter or Facebook.
That's OK too.
But if you do decide to do that,
then make sure that you
have an equally prominent--
at least, equally prominent,
equally--
ADAM KOCH: Obvious.
ROMAN NURIK: --visible.
Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: Visible.
ROMAN NURIK: --option
to share with other
things on the platform.
So if you want to do a rich
integration, that's fine.
But make sure to also offer this
as a visible alternative.
ADAM KOCH: And then lastly,
Share goes very, very well as
an action bar action, or as an
action provider, which is
something I'll talk about in
just a second as well.
Or alternatively, if it's not
a primary action for your
particular activity, you can
go into the overflow.
It's also fine to
put it in line.
That's a valid option as well.
I think a lot of the time, it
does suit the Action Bar very
well, though.
If it's primary, it goes
straight there
in the visible action.
If not, it can fall
into the overflow.
So let me very quickly talk
through the two main ways that
the Sharing action goes
into the Action Bar.
So first of all, there's the
Share Action Provider.
So it's kind of hard
to see here.
Let's zoom in a little bit.
This is how it looks.
It's going to be kind of hard
to see on the video.
But you'll see there's
a very thin outline
with the Share icon.
A little arrow in the
bottom right corner.
And then right next to that is
your most recently used, or
most frequently used application
that you've used
to share in this particular
application before.
So tapping on that Share icon
could actually brings down
this menu, which shows three
additional share options.
This is ordered by
frequency of use.
And then if you tap See All,
it'll sort of expand out to
show you the rest.
The really nice thing about this
Share Action Provider is,
it's not going to throw up
this sort big dialogue.
It feels like you're still
within your application.
And it's also bubbles up any
of the applications you're
using the share and orders
by frequency.
So it does all these things for
you while still letting
you feel like you're inside
the application.
And then, down the bottom
here, you'll see for
developers, to implement this,
a quick tip is to use the
sharecompat.configure
menu item.
It does all these things
for you in a
backward-compatible manner.
And then the other option is
just to have it as a regular
share action.
So rather than an action
provider, it's just a standard
Action item that goes in
the action bar there.
So here, you should
just use the
standard icon like I discussed.
And then call out to some
standard system share intent,
which is Action Send.
And that will fire up this
system dialogue, which goes on
top of application here.
And this is what the more recent
version of it looks
like on, I think,
Jellybean Plus.
The nice thing about this is
that it's being called by the
system, so you get this
consistent feel across all
applications that are creating
this dialogue.
It also is optimized for larger
screens, so when it
shows on, say, a 10-inch
tablet, it's
going to go into multi--
well, it's already
multi-column.
It's going to go into, probably,
three columns.
ROMAN NURIK: It's also worth
noting that you can
add items to this.
So you can pre-pend intent
to show at the top here.
So by default, it'll just show
whatever can respond to the
send intent.
But you can obviously add
things at the top.
So I think it was Pocket, or
there's some app out there
that actually introduced a
Copy to Clipboard, where
basically, you can share
directly to the clipboard to
get that URL and paste it
wherever else you want.
ADAM KOCH: And the nice about
this dialogue is, it may vary
with OS version.
Or maybe we'll change it
in a future OS version.
But as long as we call this
intent, you'll get the
standard system behavior
there.
And then, just down on the
bottom, again, for developers,
implement this intent.
Use sharecompat.intentbuildup.
And then last quick point.
You can go completely custom.
These are all available
programmatically to fetch what
applications can receive
a share intent.
Generally, it's not recommended
unless you want to
do something particularly
different.
So there's no slide for that
here, but just something to
keep in mind.
All right.
Let's keep on moving.
ROMAN NURIK: Let's keep on
rolling to full screen UIs.
So this is basically you talking
about how you deal
with system bars, like the
Status bar and the Navigation
bar, where your content is
supposed to be immersive.
So for example, photos, videos,
or books, or things
like that as you're reading.
So very quickly, just a
couple of definitions.
You have the status bar, which
contains notifications as well
as time and date--
well, not date, but time as well
as battery level, WiFi,
cell signal, things like that.
That's the Status bar,
just for terminology.
The Navigation bar is the bar
at the bottom that contains
Back, Home, and Recent.
On earlier versions of the
platform, you don't actually
have a Navigation bar.
Because you have, I
guess, soft keys.
I never know if you should
call them soft
keys or hard keys.
You have keys that are built
into the device for that.
So the Navigation bar is
something that appears on
newer devices that don't have
any sort of keys on the front.
And just in terms of sizes,
for designers, you should
obviously care about the
size of these things.
They can vary from
device to device.
There's no single standard.
And this fits in with, don't
design for one pixel
resolution.
But in case you are interested,
roughly, in
general, the Status bar
is about 25 dips tall.
And the Navigation bar
is about 48 dips.
I think on phones in landscape,
it's actually a lot
smaller, like 40 dips.
And again, don't rely
on these numbers.
These are numbers that will
probably change in the future.
And they'll probably change
on different devices.
On earlier versions of the
platform, there was this
combined bar that combined both
the Status bar and the
Navigation elements.
And this was also generally
48 dips tall.
But this is more deprecated.
So if you see screen shots,
especially, with this, they're
using the older system
UI style.
So make sure that you
plan for both.
Because if you're supporting,
for example, Android 4.0--
actually, it was 4.0?
Yes.
4.0 was using this.
If you're supporting Android 4.0
and higher, be aware that
your notifications may actually
be on the bottom
right at some point.
OK.
So there are lots of different
full screen modes.
And this slide is littered
with stuff.
But you basically have
a couple of modes.
You have Normal Mode, where
everything is visible.
You have Low Profile mode, where
the bars are visible.
And actually, you can
selectively mix and match what
happens to the status bar
and navigation bar.
But the Low Profile mode still
shows the bars, but it recedes
them visually.
So you'll notice that the status
bar here is dimmed.
You actually don't even see
the notification icon.
You see just a little dot
indicating that there's
something there.
And then your Back, Home,
and Recents are
also visually recessed.
So they're also just little
dots, hinting to the user
that, hey, there's
something here.
It's not completely
non-interactive, but touch
here to find out.
And then a couple of points.
Generally, when you use this
kind of UI, something that
works really well is overlaying
the Action bar.
So here, this is actually
the Action Bar with a
semi-transparency applied.
Another important point is, when
you touch on the content,
you should always toggle.
Right?
So you should never permanently
be in Low Profile
Mode or this other mode,
which we'll talk about.
So touching should actually
be the action
that toggles things.
And actually, in this Low
Profile Mode, you obviously
also want to hide other
UI elements as well
as the action bar.
That's actually one
thing I should
mention right after this.
So there's another mode called
Hide Navigation.
And Hide Navigation hides the
Navigation Bar at the bottom.
And it usually also hides the
top bar, the Status Bar.
So in this case, you have
full control over the
pixels on the screen.
So basically, your
app is drawing
everything to the screen.
And this works really well
for video content.
And one caveat here is that
this isn't permanent.
As soon as the user touches the
screen, the system will
automatically show the
navigation again.
Because you don't want to lock
the user into a place where
they have no access to Back,
Home, and Recents.
That's just really,
really bad.
So there's one thing I
wanted to mention.
Oh, right.
The last thing I wanted to
mention about these different
modes is, you generally want
to only switch between two,
Normal and Low Profile.
Or Normal and Hide Navigation.
And you don't want to have
different UI elements on the
screen going on and off
at different times.
You actually want to make sure
that you either have the
Status Bar, the Navigation Bar,
the Action Bar, and all
of the other UI controls all
visible, like here, or none of
them visible.
So basically, this boils down
to, make sure that the Action
Bar visibility is tied to the
visibility of the other
elements of the screen.
ADAM KOCH: The way I like to
think about this, too, is that
Low Profile is for an immersive
activity where there
may still be some user
interaction.
Like maybe you're swiping
through photos.
Maybe you're reading a book
or something like that.
Whereas the Hide Navigation is
more useful for something
where you're not interacting
with it.
Like watching video.
You're sitting back and
looking at the screen.
ROMAN NURIK: Exactly.
Exactly.
OK.
So those are the different
modes.
Just a couple of examples on
apps that do this, in our
opinion, really well.
First is Google Play Books.
So by default, you see your
actual book itself, as well as
some controls at the bottom, and
the action bar at the top.
But as soon as you touch--
well, actually, not here.
As soon as you touch the screen,
the Action Bar, the
Status Bar, and the UI control
at the bottom, the Scrubber,
they all fade out.
And then the Navigation Bar goes
into Low Profile Mode.
So what you end up seeing
is nothing but content.
Nothing but the body
of the book itself.
And then there are some actions
here for Back, Home,
and Recents, obviously.
Those should be visible.
Another nice thing that this
does is that the content
doesn't jump.
So if I touch to toggle, the
content doesn't realign itself
or re-lay itself out.
And this is possible
on Jellybean.
So in Jellybean, we introduced
some new APIs to make sure
that this is possible.
On earlier versions, it's much
harder to do that if you're
showing and hiding certain
things, like the Navigation
Bar especially.
Another app that does this
really well is Pocket.
So they're also a reading app.
But one thing that they've do
slightly differently is, they
also toggle on touch.
But they also hide the system
UI as you start scrolling.
So as you start scrolling
down, it goes
into Low Profile Mode.
It still shows the status
bar, which is good.
Because if you have an email
come in, you want to be aware
that something is happening.
And also, it shows Low Profile
Mode for the Navigation Bar.
So it's really, really subtle.
But it's very nice to let the
user really focus on the
content itself.
And lastly we have YouTube.
So YouTube is the canonical
example of a great
video-playing application.
And obviously, what YouTube
is, they hide everything
possible when you go into
this full screen mode.
So this is, again, possible with
the new Jellybean APIs.
And, oh, one thing to note is
that, in the new Jellybean
API, one of the caveats, or
consequences is that the
Navigation Bar can actually
overlay your content.
So you notice here that the
Navigation Bar is actually
cutting off the content.
So if you have something
really important at the
bottom, or I guess in this
case at the right of your
screen, you've got to make
sure that you're not
necessarily using that flag.
You probably just want
to use Low Profile.
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
And the I/O app uses the YouTube
player API, so it gets
a lot of these things
for free.
It handles all of the
full screen modes.
For you.
And then one quick
developer tip--
are we really far over?
ROMAN NURIK: Nah, it's fine.
ADAM KOCH: If you go to Eclipse,
and I think IntelliJ
or Android shortly, you can
create a full-screen activity.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
ADAM KOCH: Which kind of
implements a pretty large
chunk of this behavior for
you, at least for photo
viewing, or full screen
viewing activity here.
ROMAN NURIK: I was actually
playing with it yesterday.
I think there's a bug in it.
I'll have to fix it.
ADAM KOCH: Don't use
it yet, then.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
It's a great starting point.
It'll get you most of the way
there for almost all platform
versions, I think.
Yeah.
All right.
So we're going to fly
through design news.
So I think we're about
40 minutes.
This is obviously a
very long episode.
Let's just quickly fly through
some design news.
First, I don't know how to
pronounce their names.
I love these guys.
I think it's ah-pall-ooh?
ADAM KOCH: We think
it's Apollo.
Right?
Mikey can tell us later.
ROMAN NURIK: Oh-pa-loo,
or Apollo.
Mike on the Apollo team actually
created wrote up this
blog post called "The Holo
Grail?" Question mark.
"Android Design Guidelines--
A Realistic Approach." And it's
a really good perspective
on how do you treat
the guidelines.
Do you treat them as rules?
Do you treat them as
visual guidelines?
How can you deviate from them,
and in which cases should you?
It's not full-on in-depth.
It's not comprehensive.
But it's a nice perspective
on it.
Basically, one of the anecdotes
that he had was
that, in one of their apps,
Timer, they introduced a dark
theme that used an orange
accent color.
And a bunch of users were like,
oh, this isn't Holo.
This isn't Holo.
Because it was orange
and not blue.
And that's absolutely
not true.
You can still be in line with
the guidelines if you use your
brand's accent colors.
So definitely don't feel like
the guidelines are the end-all
be-all of design.
Next, Taylor Ling, who's been
on here a million times, has
created a UI design, UI
wire-framing kit for Google
slides, for, I guess,
for Google Docs.
And he also updated his
Photoshop version.
So if you're interested in wire
framing, high-fidelity
prototyping--
not really prototyping.
High fidelity wire frame
stuff, check
this out, for sure.
ADAM KOCH: Taylor Ling again.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So Taylor issued--
I guess, very similar to the
Android Design in Action Live
lab that we were in at I/O,
Taylor issued a redesign
challenge on his blog.
If you're interested in
participating, I think he's
giving away Google Play
gift cards as prizes.
So definitely feel free
to check it out.
And I think this
is not the one.
No.
There's one more.
You want to talk about Gmail?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
So a Gmail update went live in
Play I think yesterday, or
maybe the day before.
There's a few new design
patterns in there worth
checking out.
First of all, there's the
navigation drawer.
The official navigation drawer
pattern there is implemented
in the new Gmail app.
So we didn't have the official
screenshots of
the drawer out here.
But you can see there, it's got
the drawer affordance in
the top left.
And of course, that brings
out the drawer.
Edge swipe brings
ROMAN NURIK: This replaced the
Action Bar spinner that was
there before.
ADAM KOCH: And then there's
the refresh UI.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
So the new Gmail app also has a
new take on a swipe down to
refresh type of UI that's been
very popular in other apps.
It's not done using an elastic
band type thing.
It's done using this other
type of visuals.
We don't have it here, but it's
pretty interesting if you
want to check it out,
by all means.
One thing I will say is that
this is not an official
guideline or anything.
This is just one exploration
of how refresh can be done.
Until something gets published--
and we're not sure
if this will be published in
the guidelines-- but until
something gets published, I
wouldn't rush to implement
this in your own apps, unless
you just really want to for
some reason.
But yeah.
Refresh.
Our current best practices for
Refresh are either automatic
Refresh, not even giving the
user the option or the need to
refresh, or something
in the action
overflow, or action bar.
ADAM KOCH: It is a very
nice Holo take on
this swipe to refresh.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
I'ts cool.
ADAM KOCH: It's very cool.
ROMAN NURIK: And I
think this is--
no, that was the last one.
So the last is this new website
called screensize.es.
Screen sizes.
It's this really nice, really
quick reference to common
devices, as well as their screen
sizes and densities.
So if you're really quickly
trying to do some
back-of-the-napkin calculation
on dips or something like
that, you can hop over to this
website that has a list of
common devices.
Also, its mobile friendly, so
if you pop it open on your
Android device, it'll
look great.
And I think that's it, right?
ADAM KOCH: Yeah.
ROMAN NURIK: Yeah.
What a doozy.
So I think we promised a
doozy, and I think we
delivered a very long show.
Sorry for going way, way over,
but it's been a pleasure.
As always, I'm Roman Nurik.
ADAM KOCH: See you
later, guys.
Adam Koch here.
ROMAN NURIK: See
you next week.
ADAM KOCH: Bye.
ROMAN NURIK: Peace out.
[MUSIC]